the world economy is on a bumpy road to
recovery the US appear to grow strongly
but the developing countries still
remain in the doldrums and Europe yes
well Europe is making only slow progress
that's what are we talking about with
Oliver a call from Deutsche Bank
research mr. Rocca what does the D bigs
tell us about the current state of the
world economy the divx estate stable in
the last month and that's a third month
running that's the case and mainly there
were some minor changes on a country
base in Germany the Eiffel for example
went down a bit whereas in Japan for
example they are sentiment index went up
a bit and so far we're airing on a
stable track currently in the global
economy things have gotten lovely in the
US but developing countries still in not
a very good position why is that well
that's basically because the developing
countries are still lacking external
demand from for example or mainly
industrial countries for their products
there was some talk in the last couple
of years that may be developing
countries could develop on their own
they don't need industrial countries
anymore for the external sector that's
not true developing countries are
waiting for that external stimulus and
that hasn't happened because of weak
growth in the US and the first quarter
only weakest growth in Europe and so far
we are still expecting an acceleration
in the next couple of quarters in the
industrial countries and that should
feed through to developing countries but
we are still waiting for that okay so
the word catched football fever within
the last few weeks what does the the
World Cup brings for the global economy
well that's really a good question
historically speaking there's not a big
impact either on the positive or
negative side we have probably in the
short term some positive effects for
Brazil because of influx of tourists
some higher demand for example we also
have probably investment which we have
seen which is adding to growth in the
short term at least on the other hand
those investments could have been done
into a more fundamental infrastructure
like airports or shipping or just normal
transportation infrastructure and in
addition we have those productivity
effects people are talking about
football are maybe sleeping less less
productive and so far we have both
positive and negative effects and the
end it's probably somewhere neutral mmm
Brazil invested about 10 billion euros
for is for the infrastructure program
for the world cup and where they're able
to put some profit out of it I'm
skeptical but what about that probably
from a macro economic standpoint it
would have been better to invest in
health care system in hospitals in road
infrastructure more than they did
instead of investing in stadiums on the
other hand such an event is always very
political and but I don't think it's
it's a big positive for Brazil
necessarily especially given how
skeptical the public is about the huge
investments which have been diverted
from more social spending for example 10
billions that's a good investment and
that is something in European countries
would also like to do here especially
the crisis countries and they would like
to invest friend for example research
infrastructure and so on but they don't
have the money they would like to take
some new debt financing it with new
depths what do you think it's the time
for spending cuts over I don't hope them
so basically what we are talking about
is a little bit more flexibility and the
stability and growth pact in the
European monetary union that's
especially done by Italy and France they
want to force that whereas countries
like Germany are more skeptical because
we've done so much progress on the
fiscal front we have consolidated which
was nice
and still is necessary and so far that
would probably be a step back it's
understandable from a short-term
perspective social political perspective
but from a macro economic standpoint I'm
skeptical Thank You mr. eko growth
through fresh step this will be our key
topic this month and you can watch the
full interview on DW te / english / made
in germany